and it's not because he asked about
marijuana okay so we lost more than 150
thousand of our fellow Americans our
fellow human beings to drug overdose and
to suicide last year now we can either
accept that we can look at it as a force
of nature or an act of God or we can
understand that there may be a human
solution to some of these challenges and
problems that our fellow Americans our
fellow human beings face first of all we
should make sure that drug use drug
abuse drug addiction is treated not as a
criminal justice problem that will have
you locked up it's really no help or
hope to get right and back on your feet
and have that purpose and function that
is so fundamental to your success and
freeing yourself from those dependencies
we need to make sure that we invest in
the resources for mental health care in
America in Texas largest provider of
mental health care services in our state
is the county jail system people with
schizophrenia bipolar disorder
depression getting arrested on purpose
because it's the only way that they are
guaranteed help and then we the taxpayer
pay for them to be fed and clothed and
housed and medicated and seen
temporarily by a social worker or
therapist before they are then again on
the streets and guess what the reason
that so many people on the streets use
drugs is not that the drug use led them
to the streets they're on the streets
without access to health care and it's
the only way for them to medicate the
problems that they have so that
investment in guaranteed high quality
universal health care that investment
specifically in mental health care that
understanding that we have to boldly
change our criminal justice system to
stop penalizing people for illnesses
that they have all of that is going to
be the basis of getting this right of
reducing those numbers that I just
shared with you of getting people help
who need help right now what can we do
the wealthiest country the most
medically advanced country the world has
ever known it not be there for each
other right now especially when we have
the resources so let's do that in the
last question and again it's not the one
that made me take my sweater off we
should to this end especially since more
than half the states in the Union have
already legalized marijuana in some form
or other they've medicinal eyes it they
legalize it for recreational use we
should end the federal prohibition on
marijuana and given the fact given the
fact and listen I say this is the father
of a middle school student where middle
schools are one of the fastest growing
markets for marijuana sales today in the
black market they do not ID they do not
care as long as they can make that sale
in the same time that we've seen
marijuana use grow by kids whose brains
are still developing and it is not
healthy for them it's gonna slow their
progress and it may not make them do as
well as it would have otherwise in life
in those same 40 years tobacco use has
plummeted
we haven't outlawed it we treated it as
a public health issue we marketed
against it we made sure that it was not
cool we can do the same thing when it
comes to cannabis or when it comes to
marijuana we can free ourselves from the
distinction of being the country that
imprisons more of its fellow citizens
than any other country on the face of
the planet
and guess what by and large they do not
look like this room they are browner and
blacker than most of America though
people in this country use illegal drugs
at the same rate no matter where they
are only some face arrest faced
imprisonment and when they get out
forced to check a box that says they
have a conviction which diminishes their
opportunities in life to hold a job to
raise a family to get a student loan and
to be successful yes there's a question
about a universal basic income and this
is a really good question and I
appreciate you asking it because it gets
out the fact that even though we have
record low unemployment in this country
too many of our fellow Americans right
now in this community in my hometown of
El Paso Texas are struggling to get by
it's not just those schoolteachers
working two and three
jobs some of the people who might have
worked at that hotel that I said good
morning to when I woke up who are
working another job at the end of the
day at the end of this shift so I think
that we need to address that problem
that as productivity has gone through
the roof in this country workers wages
and incomes have not kept pace and while
some wealth in some parts of the country
continues to hold or increase in other
parts of the country we're losing it and
we're losing entire communities what are
my steps to address this I think when
everyone's well enough to work those
jobs or start a business or provide for
their family they are going to do better
economically so I think health care is
foundational when you have child care
for those little kids so that you can
return to the workforce and be at your
best you're going to be able to earn
more you're not going to be as frazzled
you're gonna be able to read to your
child before she begins the first day of
first grade you're not going to be at
your second or third job or riding the
bus home from the supermarket a minimum
wage that matches the real minimum needs
that we have in our households we need
to get to $15 an hour within the next
six years so that everyone can afford to
have that one job focus on themselves
their kids their families giving back to
their communities when I asked the clerk
behind the desk in the hotel we just
asked so tell me about Kia cook and she
said this is a community that is
distinguished itself by service by
public service our parks are cleaned by
the community it's not done at taxpayer
expense when there's a problem near the
river we all go in and get after it I
want people to have the luxury to be
able to contribute to their community to
coach their kids teams paying a living
wage I think is is part of that and then
especially in rural communities in rural
America the federal government the rest
of the country needs to form
partnerships partnerships that mean that
each side is going to give a little to
get something greater than either could
achieve on their own in Texas we have a
problem with broadband in rural
communities you may have that in Iowa as
well where farmers and ranchers and
producers literally cannot get online
where people cannot start businesses in
their hometown or finish their education
after highschool because they can't get
online they can't go to tinder and find
a date tonight to find that special
person who's going to make the
difference in their lives I want to make
sure every American has that opportunity
and if we remind ourselves of our
American history there was a moment more
than a hundred years ago where only some
cities were connected to the electricity
grid we thought some places were more
important than others the companies
corporations and businesses saw a profit
motive in some places and not in others
and so FDR and the help of members of
Congress started the rural
electrification administration and
partnered through coops with local
communities to invest in themselves with
federal backing and support let's build
up these rural communities let's get
behind our farmers and our producers
let's end these trade wars and let's
make rural America successful by
listening to our last one question is on
women's reproductive rights every woman
should be able to make her own decisions
about her own body
thank you I cannot tell you how much
this means to me
I will remember this forever every
single one of your faces and what you
were wearing what you had to drink I'm
running to serve you as president of the
United States of America thank you